pues lo que preocupa mucho es raúl que
donald trump todavía pues no ha aceptado
la derrota y ha congelado los fondos
para la transición esto obviamente
también tiene mucho efecto en la demora
en los procesos
el presidente electo joe biden tiene
4000 cargos públicos que tiene que
elegir 1200 de ellos tienen que pasar
por congreso por la aprobación del
congreso y 100 pues se están en más de
100 agencias estos cargos si se demorase
se sigue demorando esta transición pues
va a haber un problema y se va a demorar
en la aprobación de seguridad de estos
funcionarios además pues estos
funcionarios van a tener menos tiempo
para prepararse a sus cargos y ese es
importante lo que usted menciona sobre
la relación que tiene con los atentados
del 9/11 en la elección de algo contra
hamburgo donde bush llega a la
presidencia sólo tuvo bus 37 días para
hacer la transición según los reportes
de el comité del 9/11 de los atentados
del 9/11 este poco tiempo en la
transición tuvo un efecto directo
en la falta de preparación de los
funcionarios para estar mejor preparados
en casos de ataques terroristas y dijo
que esa relación directo tuvo efecto en
la facilitación que tuvieron los
terroristas para poder gestionar estos
atentados terroristas así que yo bailé
mantener si sigue este proceso lento muy
pocos días para preparar a su gabinete y
esto podría poner en juego podría poner
en riesgo la seguridad de eeuu